moi je n'affirme pas du tout que c'est
un virus et en laboratoire le problème
c'est que c'est l'hypothèse qui a été
expliqué la hourre prénom mais aussi
tout sur la chine va c'est facile de
dire l alchimie de la série nous cache
tout on aura pas parce que c'est les
chinois mais ce qui peut ce qu'on peut
savoir c'est pourquoi de l'enset publie
ce papier qui discrédite ça pourquoi
nature fait un papier d'opinion qui est
ultra critiqué il ya des gens qui
écrivent et que tout le monde prendre
pour argent comptant et c'est après
quand on gratte est bon on voit que
celui décrit dans le land cette basse et
un collaborateur de du laboratoire de
chine
c'est quand même c'est quelque chose que
vous écrire que vous raconter en détails
dans votre lit et qu'il serait quand
même très importante et qu'il se
retrouve experts de la tâche fort du 27
pour la recherche de l'origine du virus
et avec le prg et le présupposé de dire
le laboratoire c'est une théorie de
complot et qui se retrouvent experts de
l oms le plus le plus actif là bas après
vous avez l'autre c'est qui exactement
alors c'est peter d'azac qui est
président d'une ong qui collectent des
virus et qui travaille à bah oui à
collecter des virus pour anticiper les
virus à venir et puis vous avez l'autre
qui s'appelle cristiano hendersen qui
lui travaille aussi avec la chine et qui
affiche en papier avec deux autres
personnes qui travaillent avec la chine
qui était primé est qui et qui le 31
janvier écrit à fochi on l'a vu cette
semaine que il se pose des questions
parce que le virus n'a pas l'air d'avoir
répondu à l'évolution naturelle et que
donc il pourrait avoir été en générer
quoi travaillent en laboratoire et qui
quinze jours après écrit un papier en
dix ans hors de question c'est
clairement pas ça et ingénieurs jeu les
interpeller sur twitter pour kimi qu'est
ce que c'était les nouveautés parce que
il dit oui
la science a progressé c'est comme ça la
science mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya eu en
quinze jours
la seule donnée nouvelle qui a eu aucun
jour c'est les virus de pangolin qui
sont presque tombés du ciel de chine
aussi avec un mec est qui qui a fait le
papier qui travaillait aussi avec les
hommes d'arsène café ce papier dans
nature et et donc il ya ces virus qui
arrive airlines à la thèse du pangolin
qui arrivait alors qu'en fait c'est ces
virus de pongo lin sont foireux ils ont
été même reconnu nature a dit qu'il y
avait un problème avec ces virus ils
sont ils sont pas de bonne qualité et
donc si le seul truc qui fait passer de
j'ai des doutes assez impossible c'est
le virus de pangolin c'était un problème
et c'est que la science ne fonctionne
pas correctement
[Musique]